now meanwhile senator dick durbin
uh during this this hearing decided to
try to explain
why antifa is not nearly as big a threat
as the people who rioted one time in dc
two months ago
i appreciate at least that he's uh
attempting because usually
the left and the democrats they simply
ignore this point about antifa and blm
and all the rioting that they do
and have done continue to do in fact but
here at least he's trying to offer some
sort of justification
and here's what he comes up with i
joined my republican colleagues
unequivocally in condemning left-wing
violence but let's stop pretending
that the threat of antifa is equivalent
to the white supremacist threat
vandalizing a federal courthouse in
portland is a crime
it should be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law but it is not
equivalent
to a violent attempt to overturn the
results of elections
nor is it equivalent to mass shootings
targeting minority communities
this false equivalency is an insult to
the brave police officers
who were injured or lost their lives on
january 6
as well as dozens of others who've been
murdered in white supremacist attacks
we need to be abundantly clear clear
that the white supremacists and other
extremists are the most significant
domestic terrorism threat facing the
united states today
i hope everyone in this room can look at
the facts and acknowledge this
and we can come together on a bipartisan
basis to defeat this threat
we're going to move past the fact that
it sounded like he said um abundantly
queer
there and we're going to move past it
and we're not going to we're not going
to focus on that part of it
uh coming from a democratic center but
uh you know what's what's an insult he
says it's an insult to the to the police
officers well
what's an insult is that you're using
you and the other democrats
are callously using officer sicknick's
death
as a pawn as a uh as a
as a political chip that you're throwing
down on the table
you know you're using it as a prop
that's what's insulting
and it's also insulting to all of the
many
thousands of victims of antifa and blm
rioting across the country over the
summer
people had their businesses burned down
their houses burned down people who were
killed assaulted
they're terrorized in their
neighborhoods cancer-stricken children
at cancer centers
no it's insulting that you're ignoring
them and you're boiling all of that down
to
uh vandalism of a courthouse
all of that everything that you watched
happened over the summer you didn't
really see anything none of that
actually happened
you're you're imagining things it all
all of that was was was really
uh vandalism of one single courthouse
mean forget about the
forget about the police station that was
invaded
and burned to the ground sending police
officers fleeing for their lives
forget about that you know that didn't
happen either none of these things
happened it was all
uh simply vandalism of a courthouse
and yeah you're right if if you're
comparing
um the simple vandalism of a courthouse
by
some some crazy kids you're comparing
that to what happened on january
6th and the thing that happened january
6 is a lot worse
unfortunately uh dick durbin is
inventing that he's he's
he has created his own version of the
antifa riots
that's not the reality even the
so-called vandalism
no they were trying to burn it down they
were shooting like fireworks at it
this was a siege that lasted for weeks
on end
it's a lot more than graffiti even to
that courthouse
but of course the issue is not just the
courthouse
and if you were to to to you know
i say that at least dick durbin made
some attempt to um
explain why january 6 was worse than the
blm writing
whereas most democrats will ignore the
question
but he didn't really make any attempt at
all when you listen to it because he's
not acknowledging what actually happened
and and by the way uh
trying to overturn the results of the
election was there ever any chance of
that happening
was there ever any even the slightest
threat of that happening
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content